- [Caitilin] Right, so
what even is a web app?
Just taking a step back really quickly.
So, we're gonna be talking
about two big, sort of,
aspects of the code we're doing today.
So, there's the UI, the user
interface, and the server.
You can think of the
server as your computer,
the thing that's doing the computations.
But everything in the
app is gonna be updating
based on a user inputting something,
and then there's an interaction there
with the server to create an output.
So, we'll see what that
looks like in a sec.
So, you can imagine, right,
how do you guys access
the internet, right?
Your phone, it can be a desktop computer,
or a laptop, whatever it is.
Once you're on there, you're probably,
I'm sure all of you have experienced
some sort of a web app on
the internet before, right?
You access something where
you're inputting information
and something comes out as a result,
and that's all done
via a server somewhere,
so whether it's in your house
or it's somewhere very far away.
And so Shiny is a way to sort
of interface between the two,
the user interface and the server code.
So, you can think of the server code
as kind of the standard R
script that we've been writing
R code to do these computations
within our computer,
and then that's talking
to a user interface,
and this is where the
HTML comes into play.
So, we're not really
coding in HTML per se,
we're writing the Shiny
package, the library of Shiny,
is allowing you to use R
to kind of communicate
with HTML web interface,
so that way you don't need to, kind of,
from the ground up,
build your own HTML entirely web app.
Okay, so, the simplest possible
Shiny app you can write...
So, one thing, I'll
make sure we all do this
when I load up R Studio,
you'll have to install
the package Shiny so that,
it's the same way we've
installed all our packages in R.
So, that's install.packages()
and then "Shiny".
You'll have to load Shiny itself.
And then just like I said before,
at bare minimum you need
some sort of user interface,
the UI and some sort of server.
And so the script you're writing
in Shiny is gonna define
both of those things.
And then the last thing that's
happening is the Shiny app
function creates this app
building it from however
you made your UI, right?
UI is here.
And however you made your
server, server's here.
And so we're just gonna walk through
kinda of in broad strokes
what is going into each
of these components.
This fluid page part is kinda of
the HTML function way of
creating the user interface.
So, this is where we're gonna put all
of our user interface information
about what's gonna be inputted,
and what's gonna be outputted in our app.
And then the server is where our kid of
custom code is to run
computations to either make a plot
or make some sort of visualization
or produce some sort
of output (indistinct)
and that's all gonna be server.
So, we haven't really talked
much about functions yet.
I don't know if swirl got
into this at all, but essentially,
we can think of functions,
we've used many of them thus far, right?
So, ggplot plot's a function,
when you run plot with the parentheses
and putting various
arguments inside of it.
But when you wanna make your own function
to tell R to do something,
you can also do that.
So, this is what we call
creating a custom function.
So, to do that you call
the function, function,
which is kind of confusing, a function.
And there's gonna be an input
and some kind of an output.
And then the curly brackets refer
to a function that's happening.
So, we're gonna talk about
what's gonna go inside that in a minute.
Okay. So, for example,
you can make the most
boring app in the world
and run literally just this
and within the fluid page import
you can just print the
phrase, hello world.
So, if you guys want, you
can try this right now.
I can show you in a sec how to do this.
But just as an example,
running this app will literally create
a window will pop up and the words,
'hello world' will just appear there.
So, in a way that's an app
but it's not very interactive.
It's not that interesting.
So, it's not the kind of thing
we're really gonna aim for with this.
And there's no, absolutely no,
nothing happening on the server side.
Okay. Right.
So, within the user interface,
we're gonna have input
functions and output functions.
This is where, right where
the app becomes powerful.
Where you can interact with something,
you can select something,
you can type in something,
whatever it is.
And then something is produced
within the web interface.
Okay, so obviously, the
inputs can be a bunch
of different things.
Shiny provides a bunch
of these little widgets
that you can code for.
So, some examples of this,
you can input a slider as your input.
You can put in like a text box
and give you a drop-down list of things.
You can type in a number,
put in a date range.
So, there's like a whole bunch
of things you can do with this.
I'll show you guys the
main kind of landing page
where you can browse all these in a bit
but real quickly.
Okay. So, I'm gonna go
into R now just to show,
we're gonna make very,
very basic histogram app.
Just to show you kind of
the fundamentals of this.
Let me minimize this.
Can you guys see my screen still?
The R code and everything.
Okay.
So, to get started...
So, if you guys are looking
at R Studio in general,
let me push this back actually.
Is the text too small or
should I make it a bit bigger?
- [Student] Yeah, I'd
make it a little bigger.
- [Student] (indistinct)
- [Caitilin] Is that better?
- [Student] Yeah.
- [Caitilin] Or more. Okay. Alrighty.
So, in general, this is
gonna be a little bit
like R Studio etiquette for a second.
So, when you are in R Studio
I have some stuff open already
but let's say me want
to make a news script
or a new new R app.
So, in general, you can
make an R script this way.
You can just create a new R script
and then in R file will be generated.
But a really cool thing
that R Studio offers is
you can actually make
a kind of pre-populated
Shiny web app script.
So, we can do this, write Shiny web app.
And it's not gonna ask me what name do I
wanna give this application.
So, this is a folder I made already
but you can put this wherever you want.
And so this application name is actually
gonna be the name of a new folder,
that's gonna be the
directory that houses all
of the files and data
you'd need to run this app.
So, in this case,
I'm just gonna call it
just basic or something.
You have a choice here between
single and multiple file,
I prefer single file
where it's an app.R file.
And so what this means,
you know how I was showing you
there's a UI component
and a server component.
You can actually break that
down in two R scripts entirely
'cause as you kind of work on Shiny apps
and go over time,
these proportional parts
of the script get really,
really big.
So, you can make your UI
really complicated and long.
You can make your server
So, some people prefer to have those
as two complete separate scripts.
And then you call the Shiny
app function to create the kind
of merge the two together.
Okay. So, I'm gonna create this.
And so what happens, it
makes this app.R file.
I'm just gonna make this a little bigger.
Makes this app.R script and
R script is pretty great.
It kind of gives you an explanation
of like what actually goes
into making a Shiny app.
This is the Shiny web app.
This is all just
commented out information.
So obviously, you don't
need this to run anything
but just like we have before, right?
We're initializing library Shiny.
And I'll just put this.
So, in case you have not
installed this yet, right?
So, you can run this line of
code I already have on here.
So, I don't need to reinstall it.
You're gonna load Shiny.
And this is if you guys want actually,
just to see what this app is,
we're not gonna work with this app
but this is just a built in app
that's with a built-in data set that comes
with R called Faithful
and it's for the Yellowstone
old faithful Geyser
that just has different
frequencies of eruptions
and things like that.
So, this is just a small dataset there.
So, if you want, just to
see what this looks like,
I'm gonna run all of this.
And so to do this
you can either obviously hit run as normal
or you can do command + enter.
So, it's just like a
shortcut to run script.
Okay. So, this is what
this app looks like.
Does everyone see this?
So, this is our input.
This is just a little slider.
So, what this is doing is
you're setting a number of bins
and from the data it's
gonna create a histogram
of the frequency of these
eruptions of this Geyser.
But you can just see right
there is an input happening
here from the user end
but the user is also
experiencing an output.
And then the servers
computing both this plot
and doing this calculation
from the input to the output.
So, this is what we need
to write an R script
and think about.
So, it's not so much
just to create a plot,
but we wanna be able to create
something that's interactive.
Okay.
So, I'm gonna get rid
of actually all of this.
Yeah. So, actually, we
don't need that anymore.
I'm just gonna over go back here.
The other thing that's cool
about R Studio is you can
also just run the app itself.
R Studio recognizes an
app script if it ends
in this line of code
or a Shiny app call where you're
calling a UI and a server.
So, so long as the script ends with that
you don't have to
necessarily call it app.R.
You can call it really whatever you want
but you can just run the app this way.
So, it does the same thing
and it creates an app.
So, let's look at our most
boring app in the world
really quickly.
So, UI, fluid page, we're
just printing 'hello world'
defining the server.
It's not doing anything right now.
We're just creating a
function that does nothing.
There's nothing inside
these curly brackets
and then building the app.
So, running that.
And the most boring app
in the world, hello world.
But just to show you exactly
what's happening there.
Okay. So, now for kind of a slightly
like a next level sort of app,
we want to put in a special input.
So, the way that this works with Shiny is
like I was showing you
a few different examples
of like what these inputs can look like.
You can put in texts, you can
select from a drop-down menu,
you can drag a slider around.
So, for this, we're
gonna do a slider input.
And any input has this sort of structure.
Let me see, actually, it's the next. Yeah.
So, all of these input calls
are gonna end with input
and then some feature
here to define what type
of input that is.
You don't have to memorize these,
this is like a set of
lists to define each type.
And then there are at minimum
two different features here.
So, you're gonna give it a
name and that can be anything.
So, assume we call it the input ID
and then we're gonna give it a label.
So, that's what the person sees.
So, in this case, we're just
gonna call it num, N-U-M,
and then choose a number.
So, this is, what's gonna appear
on top of this little
widget, slider widget.
So, in this case, you
guys can try this out too
I just have this in here, right?
I'm just showing what more
for kind of practical purposes.
You don't actually need to
write out and 'input ID ='.
It just helps for you to
remember what that actually is.
So, this is kind of like how,
our internal name for this little input
and then a label that's gonna be seen.
And then additionally, for
something like a slider input
you actually need a few more
bits of information here.
So, you want to initialize it.
So, this value 25 is gonna be
aware that slider starts at
and then the range,
the minimum value of that slider
and the maximum value of the slider.
Right. So, this is where
when the web app comes up
you wanna see the slider
and you wanna see...
Okay.
It's gonna start at 25.
If I put in 51 here, it would start at 51.
And then the possible range
of values is one to 100.
Okay.
And then on the output side,
so this is still again,
we're still working in the user interface.
This is one thing that's gonna pop up,
that someone can input something into
when they load up the app
but then there's gonna be
an output we wanna create.
So, for this, you see
all of these functions
and an output and they all
start with something different.
Right? And so that depends
on what you actually
wanna create.
So, let's say we wanna make a
plot like we do in this case,
we're gonna run this
function, plot output.
And then give that a name as well too.
So, these names don't
matter for the point of
the person logging onto the website is not
gonna see these names.
This is how we're ID-ing
these names within our code.
Because the main thing
here is we want the UI
and the server to talk to
each other within our code.
So, these names are
important, kind of internally.
Okay. So, in this case,
we're gonna make a plot
that's gonna be a histogram
and we're just gonna call it 'hist'
but you can call it whatever you want.
And write.
Exactly. Like what I just said.
So, this is the type
of output we're gonna
display, capital output.
And the name we're to give
to that output object.
All right.
So, jumping into the server side now.
Also please stop me if
anything is confusing
because we're gonna cover
a lot today and it's yeah.
So, yeah. Just please stop
me if something is confusing.
- [Student] I just had a quick question.
- [Caitilin] Yeah.
- [Student] So, I thought
that when the server
and the UI interacted,
it was like a re-rendering process,
but from the website it doesn't
look like it's updating.
Like the page is refreshing when you...
It looks like it's all
happening on the client side.
- [Caitilin] Yeah. So, it's kind of like,
well, so the apps we're gonna
do to do today are not...
They're gonna be reactive
on the level of the UI
and the server are gonna be
kind of just like one-to-one
as soon as something happens on UI server
and is being updated, but
this is all being handled...
I mean, it's not really happening
on the client side per se,
it's happening on someone's computer.
So, that's like, all of these
Shiny apps are maintained
by a computer running R somewhere.
So, if that's your local
machine, that's fine.
Or it could be the app I'm
gonna share with you guys.
I load it up.
It's running with my
instance of R, for example.
So, it kind of depends,
but it's not completely client side run if
it just has to be-
- [Student] Okay, yeah,
yeah. That makes sense.
Thank you.
- [Caitilin] Yeah, no problem.
That part gets also kind of interesting.
Why I sort of hesitated
because there's, yeah,
there's some ways you can play with that.
So, you can like force
computations only when
something happens.
And so you can do some fun things
with the flow of computations
happening or not.
So, you can have the server
chilling out for a bit
and then running a
computation depending on
what you call it to it.
But that's more advanced so
we won't get there just yet.
Okay. So, yeah, no problem.
Is there anything else
before I jump over to server?
Does user interface generally make sense?
I know there's lots of little details
but you can think of user interfaces just
what you're seeing when you
load up this app online.
Okay.
Okay. So, there are
three things essentially
that are happening
within the server custom
function we're writing.
So, right.
This is gonna be there pretty much always
the function(input, output).
And so just to break this down,
the kind of things you put here inside
of this initial function brackets,
this goes for any R function you write.
R the kind of arguments
that you are creating to be
passed through this function.
So, in this case our arguments
are gonna be the input
and output which is what
we care about for this app.
And all of this has to live
inside of these curly brackets.
So, we're gonna be like opening this up
and running all the code inside.
So, the first thing that
has to happen is we're
going to save that object
that we named up in the UI.
So, if you remember from before,
we had this plot output and
we gave the name 'hist'.
That's gonna be the name
of the plot in this case.
And now we're using that same name
so that the server in the
UI can talk to each other
and we're calling it
by using this output$.
So, output$ can be whatever.
So, you can have multiple output
things happening in the UI
but we want to actually define
how that's being constructed.
Right? So, we're saving it first
by doing our standard
initialization arrow.
So, this is gonna be the
variable we're going to
write the code for.
Okay.
And so the way,
the most important probably part
of the server function is we
wanna actually build the object
that we're gonna display.
And so this requires a render function.
I'm putting a star here
'cause render can be
followed, not just by plot,
it can be followed by
many different things.
So, just like there are
many different outputs
or many different inputs.
There are also many
different render functions.
So, in this case, we're just worrying
about a plot, so we're rendering a plot.
You can render other things
like a table, a piece of text,
an image even.
And the format for this is
renders its own function
that has normal brackets
but it also has to have these
curly brackets as well inside.
So, you see here, I'm now opening
up this render plot to have
this curly bracket insert.
So, this is actually kind of cool.
In R Studio it kind of does this for you.
So, I have it written out here already
but we can just rewrite this
and you'll see how R Studio
kind of autocompletes this.
So, write.
We have input, output.
And I start...
As soon as I hit enter there
it already, kind of like,
tabbed itself appropriately.
R Studio is pretty good
at keeping your spacing
and tabs sort of in track,
but you have to kind of keep track
of your parentheses and
curly brackets and all that
and make sure you're closing
appropriately as you go.
And so, an easy way to
do that with E Studio,
you guys have probably
already noticed this is
you see how I when I went to
the right of this curly bracket
this left one was highlighted.
So, you can constantly check
and make sure you're closing
the appropriate parentheses.
'Cause there are many, many
parentheses in Shiny script.
Okay. So, I'm writing output
'cause I'm literally copying
but below that I'm showing
you how this sort of,
does this really.
It autocompletes for you.
So, I start having render
plots already there.
It's gonna be a curly bracket
and then I'm gonna hit enter
and it already tabs it out
for me, which is really nice.
So, in this case, we are gonna
run just a very simple...
So, this is to create a
histogram, from base R
and our norm is going to
be just creating a sort
of normal distribution for a given value.
And in this case,
that given value is
something we want to be
on the user end, right?
So, we could put just
a number here, right?
We could put just a value of any type
but that wouldn't be talking
at all to the user interface.
We want it to interact with
what we called up in the UI.
We want it to have some
sort of relationship
with what the person is
putting in to the input.
So, right.
So, the same way we call an output
we do $ after input and give it that name.
And if you guys remember,
this is what we called,
jump back really quickly.
This is what we called our slider input.
So, that's , it has to be the same name.
Otherwise the rendered
code here does not know how
to interface with the input.
Okay.
Let's make sure.
Okay. So, now we have our
very simple, simple app.
So, I'm gonna run this.
Okay. And so now we have our
real simple slider that just
is generating these different
normal distributions.
So, we can, you know,
put in whatever value for
this slide to start in
but regardless, we can still
play with and drag this around.
And then the output changes accordingly
because every time that
computation is happening
is always tied to your input
because that's how we wrote the code.
Okay.
So, does that make sense
to everyone this far?
We're gonna try kind of building
out a bit more advanced,
just working our way up
slightly more advanced features.
Let me also just grab
just to show you guys an example of this.
I'm also gonna share with you
guys the cheatsheet for Shiny,
which has all of the things
you could probably ever want
to customize your Shiny app,
But first I'm gonna show you.
So, there are many types of inputs,
like I was talking about.
So, Shiny widgets, you can go to this page
which is the widget gallery.
And so, right.
So, I was showing the slider input
but you can put an action button,
which is just this, right.
You can hit a button
and then you can actually
see the code to do this.
So, that's not what I wanted.
So, this is server side
and this is the UI side.
So, in this case, this is
splitting it into two scripts
but you can also write
this in the same way.
So, just like we had the UI
being defined as fluid page,
here we're adding an action button.
So, that's our, instead of an input,
it's just a button you can click
that has some sort of effect.
Okay.
Checkbox, checkbox group.
So, there are a bunch of
things you can do here.
Slider range, texts input.
So, all kinds of things to make your own
kind of Shiny app.
So, some of this stuff
you might wanna actually use for later
when we're building out the COVID app too.
So, a very fun thing.
That is a part of...
I usually just (indistinct) GGplot
and dplyr and as well as Shiny, obviously.
But part of these Tidyverse
packages is that it comes
with built-in datasets to kind
of play with the functions.
So, if you wanna get a sense
of what is happening in...
I'm just gonna make this full screen.
What is happening in these datasets?
You can just literally run Data.
And these are all the
datasets that are inside.
So, there's like the base,
our R Studio datasets.
So, there's a lot.
And there's also dplyr.
So, these are stuff that's
inside Tidyverse, essentially,
that come with the different
packages, which is awesome.
So, this saves us time in
having to load our new datasets.
So, we can play with the data
sets that are already here.
So, for those of you guys
that are coding along
we're gonna try out.
So, this one dataset I was
playing with today is called,
where'd it go?
It's msleep.
I can't find, I think it's in GGplot.
Yeah. This guy, msleep.
It's a mammals sleep dataset,
which I think is fun.
I love animals.
So, let me jump back here.
I can show you what
this dataset looks like.
- [Student] I just gotta say
that I never knew that you can
just write data parenthesis
and will show you all the data that's,
'cause I know how to like load data
but it's usually the
case that you just like
I just know that, "Oh yeah.
"I ran into some stack
overflow thing that said
"that this data set, it lives
somewhere in some R package."
But I didn't know you could do,
just like look at them all.
- [Caitilin] Yeah. It's pretty great.
'Cause then you can just be like
look at all this data at my disposal.
- [Student] Yeah, I'm just noticing that,
I have all these Bioconductor
packages that have this
all this extra data.
- [Caitilin] Yeah, I'm
just showing the base steps
that people don't get.
Yeah. But if you have the extra,
lots of packages come with
their own datasets is,.
is actually what I'm
trying to say. So, yeah.
There are many data sets to be had
without much work actually,
just installing the package.
We'll give it to you.
So, this dataset, mammals sleep dataset,
from X paper here from PNAS.
And so just give you a sense
of what is in this data set.
So, we have species names
or try the common names of the species.
What kind of...
Whether they're carnivoran
or herbivore their orders.
So, people who are familiar
with taxonomy at all
this is, you know,
orders, orders in animals.
So, like rodents, for
example, in order of them
or a carnivorous is also an
order an of order of mammals.
Total sleep and body weight
features as well too.
So, this is a fun dataset to look at.
So, let us jump in this guy.
Okay. So, just to start off,
this is sort of what I am setting up for.
Again, we have our UI server
and Shiny app structure.
So, first thing I wanna do always,
is to add in my inputs.
I'm thinking about how this
app is gonna look first
and then how do I build it?
So, it's helpful especially
if you're building a complex
Shiny app to kind of sketch
out, literally sketch out
or kind of like
think about how do you want
your app to look, right?
So, in this case, we're
gonna have people be
able to select an order of mammals.
So, this is just one of these
subgroups within mammals
in order to get some
information out of there.
So, I'm gonna show you first
what this dataset looks like.
So, you know what I'm talking about.
So, just to give you a sense, right?
Because you probably recognize
these guys different species.
So, order here, right.
I was trying to think of
a way to sort these guys
beyond just omnivore, carnivore.
So, people can go in and
select an order here.
There are plenty of them
and all the animals are sorted in that.
And they're gonna get some kind of output
from this information.
So, first we're gonna just
build in a select input.
So, can anyone tell me what
this is gonna look like first
just by looking at this code?
So, for select input, right?
I'm first I'm giving it my own name.
So, I'm just gonna call it order.
And this is, what's gonna be
shown to the person looking
at this app.
So, choose an order of mammals.
So, does anyone know what I'm
doing here or select input?
Or can I guess
- [Student] So, it's essentially
just like a drop-down
on all of the things that
are in there drop down.
There's just the, the names
and the orders that you
have in the data dataset.
- [Caitilin] Yep. That's exactly right.
So, I technically, I don't
actually think I even
need a write choices here,
but for me it helps just
so I know what I'm doing,
So, different inputs might
require different things.
Right. We saw with the slider
you had to put in a minimum number
or a maximum number to set
the range for the slider.
But in this case, right, I'm
just putting a list of choices.
And how am I doing that?
This is the data set
that already lives in R
'cause I have the package loaded.
So, that's msleep
and then I'm calling
a specific column here
which is order, right?
This is column.
And if for some reason, sometimes
you might also need to do,
in this case, it's not necessary
but sometimes you might need to do this
where you only select unique values.
It's not necessary here
but you can do that as
well to be double sure
you're not getting
duplicates in your drop-down.
And so I haven't put
anything into my story yet.
Haven't done anything else,
just building the app.
So, let's see what this looks like.
So, again, fairly boring.
I gave it a title and I
made this drop-down list.
So, these are all the orders that I can,
a person or anyone can select.
- [Student] So, how does it
know to not include duplicates?
Is that just like the default?
Is there a way that if
you, for some reason,
wanted to include
duplicates that you can do?
- [Caitilin] So, in
this case, there aren't.
Like you're not...
Where is it?
Yeah. So, this is the
equivalent to being like,
if, all you're...
- [Student] For all the entire drop down,
you wanted 10 carnivora
choices or something like that,
would there be a way to do that or no?
- [Caitilin] There would.
You would just have to.
Yeah. So, doing it this way,
just essentially calls the
options for this variable.
Just because you're
selecting from a data frame.
If you wanted to put in your
own manual list of things
you can literally encode that as a vector
of elements too.
So, you can definitely
do that if you want to
if you want it to be different things.
Yeah. But it makes sense, right.
In this case for everything
to be different because
- [Student] Yeah, different you're right.
Yeah. That makes sense.
But yeah, this can be like hard
coded to whatever you want.
So, this, this could be literally like,
I don't know, my brain doesn't work.
So, I'm just typing in numbers.
Like you can learn to do that and then put
in like three again, like it
can be a list like that too.
You can customize your drop
down however you want to.
But I like doing it from
a data frame driven way,
just so that you're locked into
whatever the data frame has for you.
Okay. So, right.
It's a boring app right now.
So, we wanna add some
sort of output to this.
So, again, still living in the UI
we've created a selected input
but we wanna create a plot, let's say,
because there's some pretty
cool quantitative data
in the dataset.
I'm gonna call it sleep.
One thing I also didn't mention
before is notice these comments
after everything, right?
Because these are all being called
within this fluid page function.
So, you need those comments in there
as you're adding an inputs,
do not forget the comments.
Otherwise your code will not
run and R will yell at you.
(indistinct) aside,
- [Student] Caitlin, quick question.
Is there...
There's no difference
between having a single quote
versus quotation marks?
- [Caitilin] Yeah. I
was just gonna say that.
In this case, there's no difference.
Sometimes it does matter a lot for R
but for this you can do
this, you can do this.
Oops. Don't do the colon.
Yeah. It will be the same thing.
I like to, well, it doesn't matter.
Yeah, you can do either of these.
I try to keep them like
mostly the same but if I don't
it won't affect the code
functionality at all.
You do need to have some sort of thing
if it's single or double
quotes to give it that name.
Yeah, so this is the name
we're gonna give this plot
we're making.
And we don't just wanna to make...
So, we're essentially doing this alone,
if we haven't done anything
here on the server end
we'll say, this is all
gone, this is empty here.
And we just had this.
What do you think will happen with?
What will the app look like?
So, I'm gonna comment this out quickly
just to show you guys.
So, let's say we haven't
added anything to the server.
Oops. And we just wanna run this.
What is the app gonna look like?
- [Student] It's gonna have a drop down
but it's not gonna show
anything after the drop-down.
- [Caitilin] Exactly, because
we essentially created a space
in the app, an invisible space in the app
that has a place where sleep can go,
but we haven't built anything there.
Nothing is being built
in the user interface.
We're essentially just creating slots
in our app real estate to create things.
So, let's build this thing.
So, here I am, remember
what I said before.
When you are building stuff,
here, you have to do a callback.
So, first we're gonna build an output,
build the output that we
already named as sleep.
So, it's sleep here and we're
gonna run a render function.
In this case, you wanna make a plot.
So, it's the render plot function.
And then don't forget your
parenthesis, curly brackets.
So, it's easy just to hit enter
when you do both and it
kind of indents for you.
And here, I'm just gonna
put the duty plot function.
So, what do we think
this is gonna look like
now that I've added this in?
Since you guys remember what we talked
about on Wednesday about Ggplot.
Are we gonna see anything
now or are we not
in the output space?
- [Student] I was just kinda confused
because you called the GG Function
but you didn't put anything
inside Ggplot function.
So, probably not unless
I'm missing something here.
- [Caitilin] No, you're right.
In a sense like that
we're not doing anything with the GGplot.
GGplot for it to create a
plot, it has aesthetics,
it has features, you have
to pass data into it.
It can't just operate on its own.
But what this is doing though,
is we are running a render plot function.
So, here, so it made this gray box.
And so this is the app rendering a plot
but GGplot can't you can't do anything.
So, this is the equivalent
of running GGplot.
And just getting like,
maybe like a blank graphic
or something.
It can't run GGplot because
there's nothing to run it on.
But we made this space, we've
rendered a box essentially.
'Cause we haven't passed any data into it.
- [Student] Right.
- [Caitilin] But right.
This is why this is different
from the one I did before.
Where it was just nothing
because we are actually
doing a computation,
even though it's not a full computation
of patient on the server end.
Okay. So, let's yeah.
Okay, yeah. Let's update
the layout of bit.
Right, we have our title panel.
And so now it looks a little chaotic.
So, this is how, this
is how Shiny apps work.
So, essentially what I've done,
you still see the same select input here.
Exactly the same as before,
but now we've nested it
inside of something called sidebar panel
and then (indistinct) that's
inside sidebar layout.
So, in general, what
this is doing is, again,
we're mapping out the UI space we have.
So, we're to split that into a sidebar
kind of a left space and a right space.
So, splitting out our inputs and outputs
into those respective spaces.
So, putting sidebar
layout in the front here
is gonna be surrounding everything.
Right? So, you see how this
parentheses is highlighted now?
So, everything within here
is within cyber layout.
And so there are two things we
want to put in Cyber Layout,
we wanna put a sidebar panel.
That's gonna be on the left side
and we're gonna put a main panel
and that's gonna be on the right side.
So, the left side is gonna have our input,
our drop drop-down menu.
Here.
And then on the right,
the main panel we're gonna put our plot.
Does that make sense?
This is just how we're
organizing what we're seeing.
So, above, when we ran a
word just that gray box
you guys probably noticed
that it was just one on top of the other.
Which is probably fine for now
but we wanna be able
to organize our space.
Like assuming stuff kind
of grows and changes.
We want to kind of like
utilize the real estate
that we have.
- [Student] So, Caitlin,
if I understand correctly
so the sidebar layout
splits it into a sidebar
and a main panel.
- [Caitilin] Yep, exactly.
So, that's the layout
part of the function.
- [Student] I was confused
at why the main panel would be
inside of the sidebar layout,
but the sidebar layout
creates those two spaces
and then you just fill them in. Okay.
- [Caitilin] Yes.
And so now we haven't done anything
on the server end except for
our same empty GGplot call.
So, now we're gonna run it.
Oh, that's nothing, one second.
That did not do what I wanted to.
Actually, I think it didn't work
because I didn't render the plot.
Let me just double check that.
Okay. I just wanna double check this.
I don't know why it's not.
Should be doing...
Oh, it might be actually because of my,
the window dimensions. One second
Yeah, there we go. Sorry.
So, yeah, the window
you're kind of creating
it's gonna create kind of
like a temporary window
within R Studio when
it pops out like this,
it's just running kind
of on its own little
kind of like temporary URL.
You can also open this in a browser,
I should've said before.
So, this will pop up in whatever browser
you're working with.
We're not gonna talk
about publish just yet,
'cause that's a little bit more confusing,
but just for now,
so you can see what your stuff looks like.
So, this is right, this is a sidebar space
and this is the main panel space.
And our drop-down is
still all here. Right?
Okay.
So, let's now actually do
something with this GGplot.
So, let's see.
So, I have some code here.
I want someone to tell me
what this code is doing
and you guys should be able to do this
because of what we talked
about on Wednesday.
So, right.
I had the same thing where I am creating
and building this output object, sleep.
Rendering the plot which we have before
but now I'm doing something with the data.
So, what's happening here?
This is the name of the data
frame, by the way, I forgot.
- [Student] So, you take the data frame
and you put a filter through it
so that the order of the
data matches the order
of your input into the drop-down.
And then that order will be reflected
upon the GGplot where
- [Caitilin] Yeah. What am
I graphing with the Ggplot.
- [Student] So, you're
graphing the names, right?
And the total amount of sleep.
And then I believe the
colors will be like,
there'll be separate
colors for different names.
Yeah
- [Caitilin] Exactly. Yeah.
So, this part is probably
the key part of this, right?
So, I want my output to
be related to my input.
So, I have to actually call input$order.
Order isn't random, order is the name...
Where'd it go?
Order is the name I gave the input.
So, we wanted to match,
someone's gonna choose
carnivora as their order.
And we want, the Ggplot
to be for carnivora.
We don't want it to spit
out something else, random.
If you wanted, you can
make this non-reactive
and just plot something completely random
no matter what the input is
but that really wouldn't
be a helpful or a good app.
We want it to be related
to the user input.
And yeah, this is gonna make
a bar graph essentially.
So, the geom_call is
one of these geom layers
that you can add onto GGplot to define
how we're actually gonna be plotting out
what's happening in GGplot.
Okay. So, let's take a look
at what this looks like.
So, I'm gonna run my UI, my server
and my Shiny app.
So, this keeps doing it
this way for some reason.
So, another thing I should note, right?
I didn't actually select
an initial value for this,
so when every time I load this app
because I didn't set a value.
Initially, this is gonna be empty.
If I wanted to, I could pre-fill this
this drop-down menu with something.
So, I can pre-fill it with
current number if I wanted to.
So, something is always kind of there,
but I did not do that.
So, what are we getting here?
This was just a very simple...
So, these are all the carnivoran species.
They're common names here
and this is hours of sleep.
I didn't put units here
but hours of sleep,
total sleep that each of
these species typically gets
colored by obviously,
the animal that it is.
So, it's fairly simple, right?
If I wanted to initialize it
I would have to change the input itself.
So, here where I said choices,
you can initialize this
with a value and that's
gonna be carnivora.
So, then this is what
this is gonna look like.
Oh, (indistinct) cool.
I just probably did something wrong.
Sure, yeah, I might now be able to, okay.
Anyways, we can come back to this.
I'll figure out what went wrong there,
but you can initialize
any input with whatever.
Let's say, where you can set
the slider to an initial value.
Okay. So, now we're gonna
mess with the output layout.
So, the same way we were
separating out the framework
of what the input looked like.
So, we separate it out
into a sidebar space
and a main panel space.
Now we're gonna split out
that main panel output to...
Let's say, we wanted to add another plot
to look at some other dynamic
happening in this dataset.
We can do that.
And if we were to add a plot
just without kind of
calling it separately.
So, let's say we, this
is how we actually do it.
But...
So, let's say, we actually,
let me go back up here.
Yeah, so, say here, we just
added another plot output,
some other thing and call
it plot2, whatever it is.
If we did this,
these plots would appear
on top of each other.
It would be very, very busy
and you could not really
interpret what was happening.
So, we need be able to separate out
our main panel space
and make it less clunky.
And so one way to do
this is to create tabs.
So, to do that,
it's similar to how we're
breaking down the sidebar panel
but instead of a sidebar panel,
now we have a tabset panel.
So, this is all within main panel
because this is just living
in the main panel space.
We create a tabset panel
and we're gonna make two tabs for now.
We're gonna have two plots.
So, the first tab is
gonna be exactly the same
thing that we already made.
So, for a tab panel function, right?
The first thing you want
to do is name the tab
and then what is gonna
be that output that's
inside that tab.
So, this is...
If you remember,
this is exactly the same as what we had
before we had a plot
output that we named sleep,
and this is the name of the tab.
A second panel,
I was thinking like,
"Oh, let's look at the relationship
"between body weight and sleep."
So, we're gonna go up another plot.
That's gonna have this tab title.
And the plot output in this case,
is gonna be BW, body weight.
So, this is the name we're
giving this new plot.
Okay. And so comparably, right?
For every output we name up
here, we have to build it.
So, we built one, we built this GGplot
and now we need to build this second one.
So, who wants to tell me
what this is gonna look like?
So, it's another plot,
exactly the same thing.
We're building this output named BW
or rendering a plot for it,
and we're passing msleep
into these functions.
So, what's this one gonna look like?
- [Student] Can you
just scroll back on top?
I wasn't finished with...
Okay.
- [Caitilin] Up here?
- [Student] Yeah.
- [Caitilin] Actually, I'll just do this.
So, we're running GGplot again
but now what are we uploading?
Anyone have an idea of what
this plot's gonna look like?
It's so much the first one,
but it's a little bit different
because of what we're putting
into the GGplot function.
- [Student] (indistinct)
One axis is body weight and
the other one is sleep total?
- [Caitlin] Yeah, exactly.
So, these are the names of the
actual variables themselves,
right?
So, bounce here quickly.
Body weight, that's what it's called here
and then sleep total.
But just like before,
we're first filtering
the data on the input
that the person puts in for order.
So, only for rodentia
or whatever other order.
Once that order is selected,
then we are gonna plot
for that batch of animals,
body weight, versus sleep total
and then coloring the points by name.
So, you can pick out
individual species and yeah.
So, geom_point just assigns a point
for every single data observation
and that's gonna be a scatter plot.
So, let's run the this.
Yeah, and this is aside,
I don't know how you guys are doing this
but I strongly, strongly,
strongly recommend writing scripts
and running them as you go,
instead of running the console.
It is in my mind and impossible
to do this in the console.
So, if you were doing in the console don't
because you're gonna...
It's gonna be really hard to
get this kind of architecture
of the UI of the server.
I know you guys were using
or swirl is all console based
but typically when you're coding in R
you wanna be reproducible, right?
So, you wanna run stuff,
comment on top of it,
run bits and test things out.
When you run same in the
console, it goes away.
Functionally you're not
really archiving stuff here,
except in your history
but that's not the kind
of thing you can save.
So, you wanna work with an R script.
Okay. So...
And now we have...
Let me pull this out.
Okay. So, now we have our
two spaces again, right?
Our sidebar, we have our main panel
but now you notice in our
main panel, we have two tabs.
So, these are the names
we gave the two tabs.
So, it's total sleep,
body weight versus sleep
and choose Rodentia.
And that's not readable
'cause it's really small.
And there are too many rodents species.
Let's try something smaller.
This one only has two, it's an elephant.
And if you look at body
weight versus sleep
there's kind of a big gap.
One thing you could do
to make this app better
that I'm already noticing
now that could be done,
is making fixed axes
so that you can compare across
different groups, right?
'Cause as this is changing
it's calculating
according to your dataset.
Some of these are small.
Oh, some of these have like one in each.
These are not also comprehensive,
like, every animal within each group.
Cetaceans are always fun,
got a whale, porpoise and dolphin.
Primates, our fave.
So, humans in here, obviously,
and then we can look
at the body weight too.
If you wanted to,
you can play around with this
and add more features to the plot.
If you guys had done Wednesday,
adding some regression lines,
color things differently,
look at different features.
But now we have a kind of game plan
for how to actually like layout our app,
put in some kind of an input
and break that down into bits.
- [Student] Wow. So, like,
owl monkeys, they sleep so much.
- There's also a brain weight.
Yeah. Brain weight feature too,
which is a fun thing to look at as well.
There's actually a lot
of really cool research.
that's gone into like
metabolism relationship
to brain size evolution.
So, I just find that very cool.
You can sort animals based off of
whether or not they're an
omnivore or a carnivore.
So, yeah, there's a
lot of fun data in here
that you can play with.
And one last thing,
this is the last night
I'm gonna show you guys.
Yeah. so, this is the last
thing I wanna show you guys
that's just a fun kind of added bonus.
Another package to install is this package
called shinythemes.
And this is gonna let you play
with a few presets to change
the general look of the
of the app.
So, this is not messing
with anything within the UI
or the output but it's the overall theme
and look of the app.
So, once you install this
package you can load it.
Library, shinythemes.
And now the only thing
I'm adding here is this
is this line of code.
Again, all of these
pieces within food page,
don't forget to add
that comment at the end
otherwise it won't get
added into the list.
So, I usually like to add it the top
just because it's kind of
like a overarching thing
about the app.
So, after red title panel,
I put in a shinythemes and themeselector.
So, what this is doing
if you guys haven't seen
this double colon thing,
this is the package
name, shinythemes, right?
And I'm telling R, look in this package
and find this function.
This is sometimes helpful
if R kind of messes up
and doesn't realize that package
or the function is there,
even though, you know, it is.
So, this is the way of forcing R to look
in this specific package
for the specific function.
That's what this double colon is.
And I can just show you guys
when you are typing this out.
So, I already have this here.
Oops.
And so when I did that,
I can already choose this function
that already lives inside of it.
And it'll auto-populate.
So, let me show you what this looks like.
This is literally the only
line of adding to the app.
Otherwise the same
Run this.
So, now the thing that is new
is now we have a select theme
window that's kind of floating
in the upper right.
So, this is the default theme.
It's very standard, but
you can play with this.
So, journal, everything changed a bit.
The font changed, the colors changed.
Paper, looks a little different.
I'll put something in here,
sandstone, superhero, just fun.
So, you can really...
This is just a few preset things
you can use to play around
and just kind of edit the general look.
There are ways to,
with some other tools
like CSS and JavaScript,
you can dip into HTML
and really customize the look of the app,
but for now, that's just an
easy way to play with the theme.
So, I liked superhero for example.
So, once you run this,
play around, see what
that team looks like.
You can actually access
the theme of the app.
So, theme= again, shinythemes package
and then run the actual
shinytheme function.
And it has the name superhero.
So, now when I run it, it's
gonna be the superhero theme.
Oops.
So, now the app has that.
There's no window here 'cause
I kind of just told the app
choose this theme run with this theme.
Okay, okay.
So, that is most of what I,
yeah, I think that's pretty
much everything I wanna cover.
I'm gonna just show you
guys really quickly.
We will also post these
links in the Slack for you,
but there is like really,
really good documentation
for pretty much all of Shiny
from Shiny itself and R Studio.
Which has more lessons and kind of like,
advanced things within Shiny.
But this is kind of the basics of like
how to construct an app and
how to think about an app.
Shiny does have issues when it comes
to the speed with which it runs depending
on how you're setting it up to run.
So, that's something that is
important to consider as well too.
You want to feed in, kind of
like the minimal data set.
So, it's not doing like
insane computational work
every time you try to load it.
So, it's important to keep in mind
especially like these are
relatively small data sets
but that the data sets can
change very quickly inside
especially when we're dealing
with bioinformatic data
as some of you guys already know.
So, yeah, that's an important
thing to keep in mind.
You wanna kind of keep the
computations as minimal
as possible, but yeah,
there's a lot you can do with Shiny.
So, it's very cool.